I I actually like when you were going
over I like what the player said I got
none I'm never going to show throw shade
at Dame Lillard I love him as a person
and as a player but I would have loved
to see Jaylen Bronson be a
starter I said this last year I can't
believe what a great player he's turned
into when he went to the Nixie last year
I was like that's a good signing it's
one of the best signings I've ever seen
for a free agent nobody knew he was
going to be that good you know uh he has
been fantastic he's made the Knicks
relevant and uh I would love you don't
think the Lakers signing Shaq was no
Shaq was all Hall of Famer you said one
of the greatest signings in fre it is
one of the greatest did he say that did
he say that and I'll stick by that but
it is a great free it's not it's not
bringing Shaq to Los Angeles know but sh
but listen Shaq was already one of the
best players in the world ever nobody
thought no no nobody thought jayen br
was going to be as good as he is you
don't think bringing Kevin Durant to
Golden State was a great those guys were
already made men okay nobody thought
Jaylen Bronx was going to be no he's
great I mean I'm happy for him he's
going to be an All-Star but he's going
to be an allar but but I'm saying I'm
saying that's one of the greatest free
agent sign in my op it's my opinion like
Shaq and Kevin Durant those guys Hall of
famous they were already great players
when they got treated nobody and I
guarantee you if the Nicks be honest
with you they didn't think he was be
this good they thought he would be an
upgrade but what Jaylen Bronson has did
for the Knicks he made the New York
Knicks relevant for the first time since
Patrick Ying play and simple 27 points a
game for Jaylen Brunson four rebounds
and six assists playing in 42 of their
44 games and I should point out I talked
about how close that race was between
Damen Lillard and Jaylen Brunson
actually identical finishing scores of
3.75 but because Lillard had more fan
votes that is the tiebreaker so Damen
Lillard becomes the starter for the
Eastern Conference in the back
court